i mean i can't stand any
cable news
on either side because it's what i call
my friend calls let me guess politics
name any subject let me guess where
you're going to come out on this
and it's only reporting not the truth
but the narrative the narrative it's the
thing that the narrative that you
already believe no i'm not saying there
isn't truth in it you're just leaving
out the part that you don't believe see
that's the thing about fox news when
they put me on their website they watch
a episode of real time
and then they'll only report on the 10
minutes that is the part that agrees
with what their narrative is they'll
leave out the 50 minutes where i went
after the conservatives
right maybe made fun of them
particularly and they'll just put the
part where i'm going after the some of
the craziness of the left but there is
so much craziness on the left and it's
just craziness everywhere yes they're in
our world but there didn't used to be
this much not nearly on the left
nobody was talking about abolishing the
police or getting rid of penises or
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing these
days
uh five years ago things changed a lot
in the last five years what changed it
what do you think it was that changed nz
you don't you have a problem with gen z
well we used to have a problem with bad
ideas
i remember probably but there's always
been bad ideas or just differing ideas
well let's discuss them and see what see
what's different and what's just bad
well you say gen z what about
interesting what about abolishing the
police is that just a different idea or
is that a bad idea but was that was
there well let her answer the question
counselor
is that a different idea or is that a
bad idea i think it was misunderstood
misunderstood funding the police you're
talking about right third of people
under 30 want to abolish the police i
don't think that defunding the police
abolishing the police and i think
they're two different things two
different things i don't believe in
abolishing the police i believe okay so
bad idea i believe in defense so that's
a bad idea but i've never heard abolish
the police i haven't either well i
followed the news that's my job
there was abolish the police of course
inclu and i'm saying a third of people
under 30
for abolishing the police do you not
think that it was misunders the
defunding the police was misunderstood
or misinterpreted well i think it was a
terrible phrasing of it i agree um if
you if you were talking about
reallocating funds yes and a different
kind of police training i mean
i've said things about the police over
the years nobody has ever said on
television that they weren't very happy
about so it's not like the police
doesn't need reform i get that
but you do need police we do
i agree and most of them i understand
now why a lot of them
are
kind of having a case of the little bit
of the blue flu
you know yeah because after that after
the 2020 protests
some of which turned into looting in
riots
and certainly a lot of it was just a
vitriol aimed at the police
i don't blame a lot of them for saying
you know what happened to george floyd
was horrendous
i didn't do it
i didn't do it right you know this this
idea another bad idea
that's more prevalent in the younger
generations about collective guilt
i don't believe in collective guilt of
any kind i'm an individual i'll take
responsibility for what i do or what
i've done
i don't like the term privilege
i think it's used way too much i
certainly understand why some struggling
coal miner
when you hear some rich white kid talk
about privilege it's obnoxious
[Music]